okay everyone there are three new
iPhones XR the pirate are sorry iPhone
XS iPhone Tennis okay 10 s
max okay so the names are not the best
but they are very interesting and
different in very specific ways let's
break it down from cheapest to most
expensive first up the iPhone 10 R which
starts at seven hundred and forty nine
dollars unclear what the R stands for
maybe regular people who don't want to
spend a thousand dollars on a phone the
R has a 6.1 inch screen that takes up
most of the front of the phone sorry
no home button the screen isn't a high
contrast OLED like on the higher-end 10
s it only has a single 12 megapixel
camera but it can still do some portrait
mode tricks apple says the battery life
lasts an hour and a half longer than the
iPhone 8 plus oh and it comes in so many
colors next the iPhone 10 S which starts
at nine hundred and ninety nine dollars
the 10 s is an upgrade to last year's 10
it has the same 5.8 inch OLED screen and
face ID on the front apple says the
screen is more durable should I drop
this Apple sang don't drop it there are
a few notable hardware updates first the
camera there's a new sensor in the dual
camera system improve HDR and a depth
mode so you can manually set the depth
of field in portrait mode shots then
there's a faster a 12 Bionic processor
which should make new augmented reality
applications run faster and smoother but
I'll need to test it further to tell the
difference apple says it has an extra 30
minutes of battery life compared to last
year's 10 and last the biggest and
baddest of them all the iPhone 10's max
at a once whopping but now expected 1099
it has most of the same specs as the 10s
those say new cameras and processor but
it's all in a way bigger following the
max has a 6.5 inch Super Retina screen
and it has what Apple is calling the
biggest battery it's ever put in a phone
it should last an hour and a half longer
than the iPhone 10 like the 10s the 10s
max will be available in three
so to recap the iPhone 10 are for 749
dollars shipping on October 26 and the
iPhone 10s for 999 dollars shipping on
September 21st and the iPhone 10's max
for 1099 dollars shipping on the same
day now comes the hard part which one do
you get especially when you consider
Apple's also keeping around the iPhone 7
and 8 models good news for you we'll
have reviews in the coming weeks maybe
by then now have figured out how to
pronounce the names probably you know
what the R stands for no nobody knows
what the R stands for